I am having all sorts of problems with my true-rife machine since I didn't update.
I have heard a ton of complaints online about true-rife since the company was sold,
is there anything I can do?
Well, yeah, if you have a trouble getting to your programs that I created for you, then
I would suggest that you let us fix it.
As far as people having troubles with true-rife, I would agree that there is a lot of scuttle
but online now, I belong to a Facebook group, true-rife Facebook group, and some other
rife Facebook groups, a lot of complaints online that we have been getting a lot of calls of
people having issues with their true-rife machine.
I would agree, and it's very unfortunate that the new owners are not supporting their
machines.
They don't do any support on anything, that's an F1117.
So that is, again, we'll do everything we can to fix anything that you're having issues
with.
Usually, if it's a programming issue, let's say you do an update, and again, reminder, do not
do any updates on your frequencies, on your true-rife.
We used to have people update their true-rife frequencies on a very regular basis.
Some people did it every month, some people did it every three months.
The new owners are not doing any new programs.
So there's no absolutely zero need to run an update.
So do not run any updates on your true-rife program.
But if you can't get to your programs, you have to trouble getting to your problems, just
give us a call, let us do things and work on it.
We'll be glad to help you with that.
So I don't remember somebody that called us about getting to your programs or not, but if
it's just having some issues with some quirks of the machine, we can maybe help you
too.
So let us know.